even in quarantine Britney Spears life
is in chaos
Keltie night what's going on Kevin we
can never predict the wild things that
happened to Britney Spears but lucky for
us she posts it all on social media hi
guys I'm in my gym right now but they
didn't hear for like six months because
I burnt my chimney down unfortunately I
had two candles and yeah one thing led
to another and I burned it down
Britney shared more fire details writing
quote I walked past the door to the gym
and flame boom no one was injured but
just how did this happen well we took a
deep dive into Britt's Instagram and
found this pre-fire candles set up in
her home gym a source tells et Britney
relies on candles for stress relief our
source adds her family worries because
they know Britney can get distracted and
forget these are all things she works on
in therapy and Britney dropped another
bombshell this week my prayer is with
you she's been self quarantine for weeks
and missing her boyfriend
[Music]
we're a family Brittany's been in
isolation since a recent trip to
Louisiana and says it feels like a
lifetime since she's physically been
with boyfriend Sam Ascari yesterday she
said she misses bike riding with him and
she says she's lost weight for missing
him you know I've been my life is
fitness my lifestyle fitness but so is
hers he has learned however that
Brittany and Sam have been talking every
day on the phone and facetiming
according to a source close to Sam he's
been staying at his Beverly Hills
apartment working out training clients
online and auditioning for acting jobs
on Zoom
[Music]